who knew kendall Jenner was so bold a  source close to the model tells ET she  actually made the first move on Harry  Styles I'm super excited it's a full  dream come true  ET sources Kendall and Harry have  actually been flirting for a while but  things really heated up when Kendall  invited Harry to hang out on New Year's  Eve  Kendall's sister Chloe exclusively  confirmed the budding romance to et  Thursday less than a week after Kendall  and the 1d frontman were snapped and  showed off a lot of PDA on vacation  together but I mean they were in st.  Barths together hang about dated still  our source says Kendall and Harry are  just having fun and taking it slow for  now quote it can't go anywhere serious  because of their busy schedules  vt source adds quote - Kendall doesn't  want to get hurt so she's proceeding  with caution  you